gold is gold is actually a good like if
the base collapse money collapse that's
still a good trade how do you keep your
gold these are questions of the boys
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back to another very special
episode of the careful boys where we are
very careful boys we have tests back
yeah Tess
thank you always a pleasure a lot of
Calamity out there in the financial
world as we know oh no meltdown here we
go here we go
that's a new one I've never seen you do
a lamb about you the bank you know the
banks are like oh oh Jesus right there's
a lot of oopsie dupe season oofy doofy's
happening out there do you guys have a
plan if [__] hits the fan that's a
pretty tough question to start the day
um you mean like a doomsday prep player
adult video like are you ready oh yes
I'm just gonna fly back to India baby
yeah yeah that's it I'm gonna take all
my cash
Aiden's the collapse of the banks okay
yes feed into the panic and then just go
just go straight to India it's like 75
Rupees to a dollar right now I think
but what if you can't even fly there
because there's like crazy [__] going on
right now
we'll take a cruise
no me too
I'd probably get like one nautical mile
and then sink do you think I'd probably
get life of pied for sure
do you ever think we like to [__] all
over our ancestors a lot but you're
worth it oh a thousand percent yeah yeah
it's like man there's a cruise ship
right now you can pay 30 grand a year
and and it's like
perpetually live on a cruise it has
everything you need could you live on a
cruise ship one guy is how many days
until you kill yourself bro I know I'm
not a cruise
yeah because because back during like
the piracy days and [__] and the
neighbor Warfare [__] they would suck on
limes to prevent is that why they the
racial word for white people is Cracker
because they all ate cracker on the on
the thing no I think it's because we
really like crackers it's kind of our
food you know you know what the real
meaning is that behind that is it's
actually way worse is it yeah because
it's not I always thought it was like
crackers like you know yeah cause you
know the the people that came on boats
like that's all they ate that's that's
what I thought it was but it's hard
biscuit yeah it's actually that it's
whipped cracker oh oh [__]
[Laughter]
no I thought it was like a soda cracker
have you eaten too many limes I thought
it was because we could drown out in the
sun and then like our shoulders crack a
little bit that's what I thought we can
make it that way excellent eggs
really bad do you have an actual plan
does anybody have absolutely no what
should we do oh this guy does look at
this man I have a um
I have like a bug out bag wherever I'm
at what's in it sounds like a
Nickelodeon thing
what does it have gack the most joke
thing ever would be like I don't have it
here though yeah
I have it but it's it's in the other
location it's not here but look he's
actually left wherever I go he left to
go get it I have one look the tag is
still on it and everything I love it you
ready to return it he's like I gotta go
straight back to Walmart and the funny
thing is Hannah's been like we should be
prepping can we talk about unboxing yeah
we can unbox this so you could get this
on Amazon it's pretty easy it's already
set and basically use our referral link
thank you when anything goes down you
just base the the average time you need
to survive is like three days really
like if there's a flood if there's like
any type of disaster earthquake like or
whatever it takes about three days for
rescue to get there or like if you could
survive past those days you're pretty
solid uh three days no water you're dead
yeah that's that's tough especially like
in a place like America where like it's
not like you know how recently they had
all those earthquakes and [__] in like
turkey and Syria and all that and like
um they just they they need like help
from the world right but then like the
US has enough equipment to where like if
some area got [__] up you could just
yeah you got the femas and [__] you know
he's got that backpack yeah but I got
this okay what's in it go walk us
through it yeah when we got in there
what do we got in there like all the
influencers do I got [__] tampons bro
I got tampons all right look at this
tampons yeah you got to put your hand
behind each other is that for bloody
noses bloody noses Rags was this
designed by you I got I got body warmers
I think it's cold huh is this like you
designed this yourself no no it's it
just comes it just comes I just bought
it in a set did you choose the print of
the camo print yeah I chose the princess
because you could you could either get
what kind of
and uh flashlight oh tight very good
tissue I got okay you would say that
emergency blanket emergency
straw yeah this one's like uh food ER
bar yeah what's ER bar I don't know I
don't know I just said I just said
emergency oh yeah see he's good yeah it
is
wow there's 2 000 calories water
gloves and sewing
and a in a mini tent dude you do have a
lot of stuff you know what a lot of
stuff did fit in there okay but now what
would you add like but also I have guns
so like if anything really happens you
just you just steal it but that's why
you got holster so now we know if
anyone's missing resources during the uh
Bank collapse yeah when another bank
collapses Joe's gonna have like a
bandolier or just bullets and [__]
he's gonna have a gank Squad yeah I hate
Squad ready to go so for financial
collapse I I used to have a like gold
like I had 40 Grand worth of just gold
and then I realized I want crypto
because it's gonna go harder so I sold
it all got crypto and you know you know
the rest of the story yeah the thing
about crypto he bought that back
yeah think about crypto's you can't
physically hold it and you can't walk
into a bank and physically give it to
somebody because they're just laugh at
you
and they spit your face I found it out
way late
yeah so there's that there's um well
that's a nice ring I didn't realize oh
oh this is part of my backup plan my
friend
wait wait wait wait wait wait what's
this new ring I saw my Super Bowl ring
dude this is my cult Super Bowl ring
dude you know the Indianapolis Colts
Super Bowl I bought a Super Bowl ring
how many bags can I see it am I allowed
to see this I want this thing oh God the
Colts so that
oh you forgot no you that means you
watched this last year thank you thanks
for watching I don't I don't I don't
I've never watched [__] I'm liquidating
Everything Gold is gold is actually a
good like if the base collapse money
collapse that's still a good trade how
do you keep your gold these are
questions about boys
[Laughter]
I sold it I don't have any gold left but
like
yeah where did you happen oh I have it
in a safe yeah yeah it's like those
little plates oh coins and bars yeah
whoa do you do you get it like certified
before you buy it or do you yes I buy it
from an off like like so the US mints
gold coins that are like an ounce
any people just go to Jackson Heights
and just buy a bunch of rings and
necklaces and bangles and wedding rings
and nose rings
yo but that's smart though when you're
getting married so we can like move the
gold and I'm like uh I don't know
Steve's gone but that's a good bug out
plan though because you're just like oh
okay I'm gonna sell all this stuff and
then you can buy your tickets well
that's that's what they do in India it's
like 18 karat you know 24 Karat it's
like real they're like they're like can
I bend this [__] with my fake teeth you
know like you can bend gold right
because it's more soft yeah
I heard that's like um like a special
ops kind of method too is they have a
Rolex that's not that you know it's it's
one of the less flashier types right
like a regular uh Day date like a yeah
like
yeah like a GMT or something that's just
blank like a Pepsi yeah why just uh no
you can sell it for like 8K or something
oh it's like five depends yeah they just
can't call the government and he's like
wait we're supposed to sell it
turns it into a bar and then brings it
to the pawn shop yes it goes in the Box
Shop he's like so I have my belted Rolex
they're like three dollars they're like
I got it I got it do you actually have a
plan for yourself uh well I was thinking
about this because Bart actually texted
us about this yeah he was like well hey
um I got maybe an idea for the show and
I was like damn of course he's not here
I know exactly he probably had an answer
that's why he goes well I can't wait to
tell him well he's like I'll sell my
storage containers so relatable everyone
at home can do that too and then
today's video is brought to you by
Sunday okay Winter's over it's
springtime baby and all of the flowers
be blooming but let's say you have a
beautiful lawn and you don't even know
what to do with it
well guess what Sunday got you covered
Sunday is everything that you need to
get the lawn that you dreamed of this
spring go to getsunday.com off the
Record and enter your address to get a
customized plan created just for your
lawn no trips to the store or hauling
heavy bags because they shipped straight
to your home
okay you see this here you put this in
here and all you need is a hose to apply
on this end that's it where the water
goes through
pick up fertilizer a whole lot and less
than the time it takes to watch a full
episode of your favorite show how
wonderful that's fast and they only use
ingredients that you can feel good about
no harsh chemicals no long waiting
periods or trying to keep your kids and
pets off the lawn simply apply let it
dry and you're back to enjoying your
yard Sunday is easy and affordable some
lawn care services cost more than
fifteen hundred dollars a year but
Sunday's full season plans start just at
a hundred and nine dollars
and Sunday is offering our listeners 20
Off full season plans start at just a
hundred and nine dollars and you can get
20 off when you visit getsunday.com off
the Record at checkout that's 20 off
your custom plan at getsunday.com off
the Record Mark's trying to help the
every man yeah yeah exactly no I I would
obviously gotta liquidate my cryptos
first so that sucks but did you do that
already no no no no no I got mad
positions baby but
um bro yeah come on look at me come on
dude hey we're on the goals of the
outfit we are on the comeback but yeah I
would like I would liquidate my cryptos
first and then obviously like we have a
house I would I would just sell it for
cash at a drugstore probably
he's like we got a water heater in the
basement don't worry we got some cash
does anyone want to buy a house you know
I don't walk around the drugstore for a
while we're walking to the parking lot
is what I would do I wouldn't eat yeah
yeah right so listen dude I think it
would depend on the type of like Fallout
like are we talking about like it's like
riots everywhere and it's like a real
Fallout like Zombieland [__] or is it
like natural disaster or like I don't
know because then you have to be prepped
for all that [__] I used to watch
Doomsday Preppers that was one of my
favorite shows I love that show yeah I
like that show and I like watching
people like build shelters in their
backyards on YouTube [__] cracks me up
like guys digging holes digging holes
for days right next to their house yeah
they pour concrete into their backyard
and [__] fill it up just in case your
main primer house collapses there's a
house six feet right next to it which
won't be affected by whatever issue in
your house
then if there's a power outage you got
like nuclear situation it's like yeah
everyone knows it you have this everyone
you told YouTube and it has like 12
million views and they're gonna come and
get you yeah can you monetize it every
three minutes you're gonna steal all
this yeah I know we're gonna build an
army and just go get it have you seen
the out in classrooms now they made this
uh bro that's a cool shooter wall
um like if there's a school shooter it
like folds into the wall and you pull it
out so it's like a separate entrance and
it's bulletproof so it's like a right
angle like wall wall and then it folds
out like this and it makes another room
that you can hide in WoW bulletproof
rooms that's crazy I love playing
defense
[Laughter]
that's what Tony Dungy says dude he says
it wins championships that's what double
team taught us I think I'd be [__] if
something were to go down because I
don't have [__]
yeah not many skills huh you might
survive not many skills but I think you
can really edit videos during the
during the apoc he's thinking about it
he's like but if it were to happen
um I have friends so you know I could
just ask people for help you freeloader
yeah he's sitting next to you I don't
think he's gonna help you I don't think
Joe's gonna help you
uh realistically I would probably try to
find ways to help people if they were
willing to like give me whatever be a
part of a yeah be a part of a community
or make a like a resistance yeah like I
don't have any money to offer because
like money is probably not worth
anything anymore but you can offer your
time yeah
he's gonna be the first tax deductible
charity post the apocalypse guaranteed
donate to this board I have nothing to
offer but time and ass dude
dude he's a guy he's a guy that I he's a
guy that I find when I play Pirate game
and he's being nice and I'm like oh this
is gonna be fun oh no he's gonna tie you
to the mask he's gonna force feed you
oranges and lives you got scarvy [__] I
vote him into jail immediately
the [__] like the [__] ukulele
around him like while I'm topping around
yeah he's stealing things out of his
cabinets
I feel like um Nevada is gonna be like
Mad Max and I feel like Silicon Valley
is gonna be like this crazy
future Utopia with the Mad wall and
everyone inside is like like super like
organized and clean and like intelligent
but then like they're like something odd
about this city yeah you think that's
that's gonna be Vegas uh Nevada but out
like the Nevada people is going to be
like Mad Max got it up like and what
about the California I think it's gonna
flip what about us really so San
Francisco 's Mad Max yo yeah I think
everyone invas
like you know I've got a yard
space yeah people in Silicon Valley be
like I think someone's [__] in my
[__] bathtub
yeah that's true if they're still living
there there's people [__] like on
their roof right now
I still live here [__] then how
hard are we in Vegas dude because
honestly in Vegas like I I chilled on my
road rage a lot because I'm like
everybody here strapped so I don't know
do you think do you think uh the mole
people are gonna crawl out I'm terrified
so like
there's like 20 000 homeless folks in
the tunnels under Vegas right so if
Fallout happens they're all gonna crawl
out nice or stay there oh they're like
yeah
well you know oh yeah I bet if they open
an underground Casino it'd be you'd be
lit that would be nice I bet they have
one now a hundred percent they just
don't take American currency what do
they take rat tails used hairs
have you guys ever seen anyone win at
the airport my sister has has she really
like it has that she I think she she
probably doesn't even remember because
we were underage and she just went and
pulled the thing like my dad put the
money in yeah I think she won like 50
bucks but it was a slot machine she just
walked over but like there are there
jackpots at the airport like where
they're in there yeah I always wonder if
you win a jackpot at the airport you're
the luckiest guy yeah cause you're like
I'm out dude or you're in like or
imagine you're feeding it dude you're
feeding that one machine I would miss a
flight for that yeah or you keep going
back to the airport because like that
machine's gonna hit
good morning cold it's gonna hit I've
been doing this for two years I'm going
to Vegas today oh you're gonna gamble do
you play straight from here no just
Blackjack sometimes I don't gamble too
much With Buddies if we all go play I'll
play lose all my money are you an
advantage player I see like I don't even
know what the [__] that means okay yeah
they want your business they love you
yeah but I like I don't play anything
but Blackjack if I go to Vegas because
it's really the only game I know how to
play
oh we got to play craps then because as
a group yes if you're a social player
that game is fun they got me into it
like I go and be like okay here's the
money I'm gonna spend here's the money
I'm gonna lose
that's my good time
I need to get it back I need to get it
back
other things that's what we do that's
what we do yeah yeah you know well I
don't like gambling I gamble with these
guys and I saw how much money they're
throwing on the table that's Bart dude
it was it was everybody it was Joe Joe's
like another hundred no Bart Bart is a
Madman I didn't realize
hover over the table with like a 500
chip and he'll watch the roller and
he'll just drop it before the Roll Just
because he has a feeling about it
are you sure people are just aren't
scared of him because he's standing
there like this he's like looking at the
guy he's like are you gonna do it and
his muscles are just really yeah that
could be like he's like
but he drops it and then they wipe it
he's got his barbell gay t-shirt he's
like You're Gonna Roll It
the funniest things I remember how you
guys were saying like oh man it's just
fun as a group it's really fun and then
I remember watching they put all this
money they lost it they went well
I was like yeah that looks really fun
that was Circus Circus though we're
never going back yeah oh you went to
Circus Circus
Circus Circus we're never going I saw
the old sad soul that's like the
outskirts man it's like when you drive
in you're like oh [__] are people still
alive in there like right well we had a
good run at the Stratosphere we had we
go to [__] casinos and have good runs
but not Circus Circus we're done there
we're done they won't get our business
again guys you guys gotta tell me the
spots because we had to hack we had to
[__] haggle them to open the table
over the [__] table there's like I
got 16 people I brought here come on how
much and this guy's like I don't know
you guys seem like cheap asses to me and
I was like I was like we're gonna play
baby if you show them the ring you
should have popped it right here
yeah
and then he opened it up and we're out
of there nine minutes
that's why
shaking our [__] wallets out of the
table that's ridiculous inside out man I
love it so I guess if uh you have no
plan dude I don't have any plan I have
no plan yeah last time some like
something like this hit the fan it was
like coveted right everybody was like
freaking out it was like early covet
when everyone was like oh my God there's
tanks rolling in the the countries being
shut down what's gonna happen I just get
a text from [__] from from from Joe
and he's like we need to gather our
resources like I was like we're all
neighbors bro he's like he's like if if
anything [__] hits a fan we all meet it
together I've never honestly felt more
safe in my life I was like yeah but I
was like bro Joe's got this figured out
I didn't even think about it yeah
there's like I had like three months of
survival I was like you guys could come
over my my place I had a three bedroom
home at the time I was living alone and
then I was a day I had him and my other
buddy that was a couple blocks away and
David so I was like just come here and
that's it I was like between all of us
it'll be great David's learning how to
grow tomatoes dude he won't shut up
about it he could be the he could be the
cook because I don't I won't trust him
with a gun he'll probably shoot one of
us in the back trying to hit somebody
dude you always need to cook and you
always need a medic those are the two
under you don't have a medic yet but
we'll figure it out dude you're the
medic dude my other buddies he's the
Jeweler oh he's a jeweler yeah he would
well maybe he wouldn't be because then
he had gold the Jeweler you don't need a
jeweler the first thing that happens to
him is he gets completely cleaned out
we're a bigger Target because he's a
jeweler yeah yeah and you're like please
I can fight you with my hands but if you
have a gun oh [__] you're like you see
all these diamonds harness material on
Earth I'll [__] you [__] you up it's
like what do you mean knives dude you're
gonna use knives on me
oh no don't punch me punch meals rings
flicker mix the Nix the fighter he's the
guard the house guard I'll throw the ass
dude just you and your pups yeah dude
just our two pug guards yes they're like
this big don't make fun of my dogs I'm
not wait don't you have like eight pugs
right now oh yeah now we have two at the
house oh they they were giving away are
you breeders might be
so we found a pug on the street my
mother-in-law did and it turned out to
be pregnant
so he found one pug we found one female
pug we brought it in turn out to have
eight babies and then now we have
[__] 11 dogs in the house but what
were the odds right because then that
means daddy pug daddy daddy was a pug
too when that when that pug gave birth
we were like this is gonna be like mixed
with pit or something yeah no way it's
gonna be pug did you find the plug in
your mailbox
I'm thinking about a pregnant pug is it
or like it was it not visible it wasn't
visible and then then it became visible
well and then the cheat she started
sagging right and you're like what's
going on and we were denied all the time
like no way no way medical terms yeah
I know your dad's a doctor but like I
watch crazy you know
so yeah now we have [__] 11 dogs in
the house so it's great it's a good time
eleven can you name them all how much
does Super go for 101 dominoes hey man
let's talk on camera
I pay cash yo getting the DMS for the
plugs you take Super Bowl rings
they had ten [__] pups dude you
should I know pugs could have so many
goddamn bubs the pup is like this [__]
yeah we got the wrong we got oh you took
the run so you got the Charlotte's Web
what does that mean like the pig
Charlotte's what was your memory
Charlotte's Web the pig what was the Run
yeah she was the baby no not babe no
like Templeton Templeton oh yeah
obviously honestly everyone kept saying
like when the puppies gave birth they're
like you better watch out better make
sure none of them die and I was like
what but that happens though right I
know but apparently it happens all the
time but we we all of them work all good
so are you bottle feeding pugs over
there we no not not really we we had a
little glass saucer a little saucer with
milk in there that's cute I got baby
formula I was making that up this
morning
you're giving the Pug Similac I don't
even know what that's baby formula
you should just train your pugs to like
do stuff for you like dude trying to
train them to sit is like a pain in the
ass they just shouldn't piss everywhere
kind of but they're cute though
that's crazy aren't you supposed to wait
like uh three weeks or some [__] until
you give them away because they have
they need titty milk they're eight weeks
old wow nine weeks are you gonna give
them away we gave some away did you give
them away for a low price yeah
for donations
I can't wait till next month when you
find another freaking [__]
you're like Nick where did you get a
grill dude
[Laughter]
it looks like looks like it's so weird
we had to anyway we had to buy office
space
dude where'd you get a Rolls-Royce
Phantom
I'm in the Pug business baby SUV
foreign